قد تكون مصر اكثر المتاثرين سلبا على
الصعيد الاقتصادي جراء الصراع العسكري في
السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
هكذا يرى خبراء هذا المشهد يقول هؤلاء ان
تداعيات القتال في السودان على الاقتصاد
المصري من المرجح ان تعرقل مساعي القاهره
لتامين القروض التي تحتاجها من المؤسسات
الدوليه لاسيما صندوق النقد الدولي فعل
سبيل المثال يواجه التبادل التجاري بين
مصر والسودان ازمه كبيره نظرا لازدهار
العلاقات بين البلدين فقد ارتفع حجم تجاره
الثنائيه باكثر من 18% خلال العام الماضي
وفقا لبيانات الجهاز المركزي للتعبئه
العامه والاحصاء المصري وتجاوز حجم
التبادل التجاري مليارا و400 مليون دولار
ارتفاعا من نحو مليار و200 مليون دولار في
عام 2021
ويستحوذ السودان اجمالا على ما يزيد على
13% من اجمالي قيمه التبادل التجاري مع
الافريقيه وتخطت قيمه صادرات السودان الى
مصر خلال العام الماضي نصف مليار دولار
وتصدر مصر للسودان مواد البناء والتشييد
مثل الاسمنت والحديد والسيراميك والدهانات
فضلا عن الاجهزه الكهربائيه والكيماويات
والاغذيه المصنعه في المقابل تشكل اللحوم
الهيكل الاساسيه لواردات مصر من السودان
اضافه الى العديد من المنتجات الزراعيه
والمواد الزيتيه والحيوانات الحيه والسمسم
والفول السوداني والقطن والمنتجات الزيتيه
والصمغ العربي وهنا يقرع الخبره او ناقوس
الخطر من ان الامن الغذائيه لمصر سيتاثر
سلبا نتيجه نقص هذه المواد المستورده من
السودان خصوصا ان تداعيات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا في سوق الحبوب العالميه ما زالت
مستمره
وفي مجال البنيه التحتيه تشترك مصر
والسودان في مشروعات عده اهمها الربط
الكهربائي بمقدار 300
على المدى البعيد كما تستغلان نهرا النيل
للنقل النهري مع وجود خطط للربط بين
البلدين عبر السكك الحديديه وسط مساع
لانشاء خط من اسوان الى الخرطوم لكنها خطط
تبقى رهن تطور الاقتصادي في السودان الذي
يعاني من تباطؤ النمو بشكل ملحوظ خلال
السنوات الخمس الاخيره ما ادى الى تراجع
قيمه اجمالي الناتج المحلي من 60 مليار
دولار الى 35 مليارا يبدو ان المخاوف من
استمرار الازمه السودانيه دفعت وكاله
موديس للتصنيف الائتماني للتحذير من ان
الاموال التي تحصل عليها دول الجوار مصر
وتشاد وجنوب السودان واثيوبيا من بنوك
التنميه متعدده الاطراف ستتاثر بشكل كبير
نتيجه القتال في كما يتوقع ان تدفع الازمه
المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه الى زياده كلفه
الاقراض والفوائد على القروض التي ستمنحها
ففي العاده تتراوح الفوائد المفروضه على
مصر من جانب هذه المؤسسات ما بين اربعه
وخمسه في المئه لكنها مرشحه لكي تصل الى
اكثر من ثمانيه في المئه ياتي ذلك في وقت
اعلنت فيه وكاله ستاندردان تخفيض تصنيفها
لمصر من مستقر الى سلبي بسبب الحاجه
الكبيره للتمويلات الخارجيه بهدف ضبط عجز
الميزان التجاري والدين الخارجي ولا
يستبعد خبراء ان يؤدي هذا التصنيف الى
انسحاب مستثمرين لتصبح محصلته مزيدا من
تهاوي الجنيه المصري امام الدولار